der gigantische algen gürtel reich von
mexiko bis nach westafrika und bildet
eine einzige todeszone
die rede ist von der brown alias um die
sich in den letzten jahren in rasanter
geschwindigkeit ausgebreitet hat und
unter der riesigen menge leidet nicht
nur der tourismus sondern auch ganze
ökosysteme tiere können sich nicht mehr
bewegen oder eier ablegen und der
seetang schwenkt sie sogar in ihrer
atmung einen forschungsteams befürchten
dass dies auf eine veränderung der ozean
chemie zurückzuführen sein muss die
langfristigen folgen sind noch nicht
absehbar
doch satellitenaufnahmen der nasa zeigen
jetzt das ganze wirklich verheerende
ausmaß klicks und science fiction hier
gibt es täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen heute aus
kopenhagen an der ostsee hier hinter mir
in der ostsee da schwimmt die typische
braunalgen sie wird auch seetang genannt
und enthält luftblasen damit sie auch
oben auf dem wasser schwimmt am strand
findet man sie oft aber es ist hier an
der ostsee noch lange keine braune flut
unter experten und expertinnen wird das
phänomen die braunalgen invasion
zwischen mexiko und westafrika nämlich
auch als brown teilt also braune flut
bezeichnet beobachtet werden kann dass
wenn braunalgen an die küste driften und
sich dort in der brandung und am strand
verfilzen dass es derzeit der fall und
zwar unter anderem an west afrikanischen
und karibischen küste das paradies in
diesen regionen wird zu einer todeszone
die braunalgen bilden ein teppich des
todes der alles leben darin und darunter
zerstört es entsteht eine meter hohe
masse die extrem nach faulen eiern
stinkt nicht nur fische sondern auch
viele andere lebewesen ersticken
in dieser algen masse oder verstricken
sich darin darunter auch delfine
schildkröten und vögel die sich nicht
mehr aus dem algenteppich befreien
können und sterben im jahr 2011 wurde
dieses todbringende phänomen zum ersten
mal an westafrikanische und karibischen
küste beobachtet seitdem gibt es sogar
ein frühwarnsystem für die satzung
blüten das sogenannte sogar zum watch
system se cabrio es und jetzt hat sich
ein us forschungsteam der dem extrem
wachstum der braun alge in den
vergangenen jahren erstmalig genauer
gewidmet dazu wurden daten aus den
jahren 2000 bis 2010 analysiert der
nasa-satellit aufgenommen hatte das ist
möglich weil die besagten brown haben
neben dem photosynthese pigment
chlorophyll auch noch den farbstoff
namens folk santín aufweisen so zeichnen
sie sich durch ein charakteristisches
farbspektrum aus dass sie von allen
anderen alben gut unterscheidet und eben
auch aus dem weltall zu erkennen lässt
das ergebnis der fachleute ist nicht nur
eindeutig sondern auch besorgniserregend
seit 2011 haben sich die frei
schwimmenden sackgasse um algen
explosionsartig vermehrt 2011 waren sie
vor allem östlich von florida in der
sogenannten saragossa see und rund um
den golf von mexiko zu finden dann
begann allerdings die ausbreitungen der
algen in andere regionen unter anderem
in den zentralen atlantik 2018 reicht in
der alten gürtel dann vom golf von
mexiko bis zur westafrikanischen küste
mehr als 20 millionen tonnen der
braunalgen schwammen schätzungen zufolge
im vergangenen jahr auf der
ozeanoberfläche im atlantik erstreckt
sich das band an braunalgen über
unglaubliche 8850 kilometer die
dichtesten konzentrationen konnten in
der karibik und vor der nördlichen küste
südamerikas identifiziert werden laut
der aktuellen studie ein relativ neues
problem denn von der jahrtausendwende an
bis zum jahr 2010 gab es keine
ausgedehnten brauen algenblüten in der
karibik und im zentralen atlantik und
auch die historischen daten offenbarten
das ist bislang keine braunen
algenblüten gab die vergleichbar wären
eigentlich sind die algen auch gar nicht
problematisch im gegenteil sie bilden
schwimmenden matten und spielen so eine
extrem wichtige rolle im ökosystem der
ozeane
denn sie produzieren durch photosynthese
nicht nur sauerstoff wie andere pflanzen
auch sondern bieten auch guten schutz
für fische schildkröten vögel und andere
tiere doch die extreme ausbreitung der
braunalgen verwandelt das paradies zu
einer einzigen todeszone korallen und
see gräser werden in ihrem ökologischen
gleichgewicht gestört wenn die toten
alten sinken auf dem meeresgrund die
braunalgen an der wasseroberfläche an
den küsten und in der brandung
verhindern dass sich die tiere frei
bewegen können der seetang schränkt
manche tiere auch in der atmung ein und
verhindert die eiablage an den küsten
und nicht nur das auch der tourismus
spürt negativfolgen der algen in version
war aber das hat im vergangenen jahr den
nationalen notstand ausgerufen der
seetang verrottet am strand und
schwefelwasserstoff entweichen
so stinkt es wirklich unangenehm nach
faulen eiern und nicht nur das das gas
kann auch für benommenheit übelkeit und
kopfschmerzen sorgen klar dass die
touristen fern bleiben ein großes
problem für länder deren wirtschaft von
dieser branche abhängig ist soldaten
versuchen mit räumfahrzeugen gegen die
alten flug anzukämpfen
auch die bevölkerung hilft mit 2018 hat
den wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler des ibiza an der
texanischen küste ausgerufen und viele
menschen kamen um dieses stinkendem
berge an seetang mit hilfe von rechen-
und schubkarren zu entfernen weltweit
suchen forschungsteams nach den ursachen
für diese explosionsartige ausbreitung
der alten klar ist dass das wachstum der
alben von der meerestemperatur der
sonneneinstrahlung und dem
nährstoffangebot abhängt
höchstwahrscheinlich sind mehrere
faktoren zu beachten zum einen das im
winter wasserschichten aus der tiefe vor
der westafrikanischen küste nach oben
aufsteigen und somit nährstoffe an die
oberfläche spülen dies begünstigt das
wachstum der algen aber auch wir
menschen sind wohl nicht ganz unschuldig
an der alten version
denn die nährstoffe menge die in den
ozean gelangt ist durch uns extrem
angestiegen zum einen durch den einsatz
von düngemitteln aber auch durch die
abholzung der wälder große flächen
amazoniens wurden in viehweiden und
felder umgewandelt die intensiv gedüngt
werden dadurch gelangen phosphate und
nitrate in den amazonas wer es weiter
ins meer spült doch nicht nur das auch
die zunehmende erwärmung der
meeresoberfläche sorgt für optimale
bedingungen für das algenwachstum
weitere nährstoffe gelangen auch durch
staubstürme aus der sahara ins meer
vor allem der einsatz von düngemitteln
wurde ab 2010 auch noch intensiviert
dazu vernahm ihn der an der studie
beteiligt war
ab diesem zeitpunkt muss ich die chemie
des ozeans geändert haben dass die
blüten völlig außer kontrolle gerieten
welche folgen die braunalgen langfristig
haben könnten ist nach ansicht der
fachleute derzeit noch nicht wirklich
abzusehen
doch das us forschungsteam
prognostiziert dass diese
explosionsartige ausbreitung der braun
alben auch in den kommenden jahren
weitergehen wird dazu yuan - wenn man
sich die daten aus den letzten 20 jahren
anschaut ist es wahrscheinlich dass
dieser gürtel in zukunft normalität
werden wird schließlich wird die
überdüngung der meere weitergehen ebenso
wie die zunehmende erhöhung der
meerestemperaturen vor allem die karibik
aber auch die
südamerikas und auch florida müssen wohl
in zukunft mit den braunalgen leben doch
das könnte auch eine chance sein die
wissenschaftlerin hazel oxenford meint
dass mit dem neuen alten schwerpunkt
zwischen der brasilianischen und
westafrikanischen küste langfristig
vielleicht sogar ein neues ökosystem
entstehen könnte sie nennt es sah gossow
süd eine folge des klimawandels und eine
weitere ist wahrscheinlich die
hitzewelle 2018 durch menschengemachten
klimawandel verursacht anklicken
anschauen und vor allem klicks um nature
abonnieren das ist ein neuer kanal den
ich gerade aufgemacht habe da gibt es
regelmäßig videos rund um umwelt und
natur nur mit dem abo verpasste nichts
also bis dann bleibt dran